[Applause]  for the man accused of stabbing eight  people on the Las Vegas Strip last week  appeared in court this morning 32 year  old Yoni Barrios is charged with open  murder two people were killed in the  attack outside of the Wind Resort on  Thursday during today's hearing barrio's  public defender says he needs to address  his clients competency before moving  forward  if there's a finding that he's not  competent to move forward what's going  to happen is going to be sent to it  state facility for evaluation either  lights Crossing in Reno or Stein here in  Las Vegas and they would try to restore  him to competency through medication uh  some kind of any kind of psychological  Council  Barrios is being held without bail his  next hearing is set for January of next  year